well the doctor may not like goodbyes
but mafia sure does okay folks here we
are we have arrived at the exit from the
show for Amy and Rory Angels Take
Manhattan this one is a really sort of
odd mix so here's what it has going for
it
it is incredibly heartfelt the emotional
resonance it has for me he feels very
well earned not only in the episode of
itself but also because of the of the
groundwork laid by the episodes leading
up to it in this series I've knocked on
series 7 before for being sort of split
in half and disjointed and I stand by
that but I will say in terms of building
up specifically to the exit of Amy and
Rory good work was done in the episodes
that preceded this even though I don't
especially love those episodes in and of
themselves they did set up things very
well for this piece so that works quite
well
it's atmospheric it's tense it's got a
really good sense of pace river's back I
do enjoy a river quite a bit I find some
of the time you want us to be very
clever but also stick a pin in that
we'll come back to that in just a little
bit the performances are really good
honestly from everybody we watching this
I forgotten how good River was in this
especially towards the end at the actual
sort of farewell but again I will come
back to that and yet despite all this
man this episode doesn't make a lick of
sense like it's it's preposterous now
look first off I am actually totally
fine with doctor who has a show having
somewhat malleable or inconsistent
time-travel rules I'm fine with that and
I will always be fine with that beak
I don't feel like it does the show any
favors to lockdown to that this is the
only way that time travel works so I am
totally cool with the idea of sometimes
events are fixed sometimes there's not
sometimes a change can be catastrophic
sometimes a change doesn't matter the
slightest
I am totally down with that kind of
malleability because it frees the show
up to tell a lot of different stories
what I do ask however is that any given
episode be consistent in which set of
rules its operating under and this one
oh boy
Moffett just breaks all his own rules
that he is set up not only for the
weeping angels but also for time travel
in this specific episode huge swathes of
the plot pin themselves on the fact of
that once you know the future you cannot
change it it is fixing there's nothing
you can do
oh except look at that we did change it
except oh no wait maybe we kind of
didn't except we did but now we didn't
but now they're back and we can't go
back and make up your freaking mind it
really does feel like he got very stuck
in with sort of with the emitted
cleverness of the weeping angels and the
idea of the of the building full of
batteries they just keep zapping them
back in time to that same loop and just
keep feeding off the that's actually a
pretty neat idea and also kind of
horrifying that's a nice scary idea for
the angels but then the only way to beat
them once they see old Rory is to break
all the rules but then at the very end
still have things happen the way they're
supposed to maybe kind of sort of it
again I don't have a problem with the
show great on a grand scale being
wishy-washy and indeterminate with how
it handles time travel but you can't be
this all over the shop in a single
episode and I mean especially with the
weeping angels cuz the weeping angels by
their nature lend themselves to the
harder set of rules that's kind of what
they were built to do so the
malleability of the idea of you know we
can break all this if we caused a
paradox but like the whole idea we
paired
as you're supposed to not be able to do
them at all not I mean well I take that
back because dr. who has done both
they've done you're not supposed to be
able to do them at all and they've done
you can do them but they're incredibly
dangerous but more often than not I feel
like dr. who has erred on the side of
when you try to create a paradox it just
doesn't work and but here they can
because it's Amy and Rory and I say that
like a little bit sarcastically is
that's a dumb reason but at the same
time I do honestly really love the
moment where they're trying to figure
out how can we possibly you know get him
out of here we've just seen him die and
he just takes Rory's hand and says I
won't let them take him I love that
because I love Amy and I love her and
Rory together so emotionally all the
beats are correct in this it's just the
logistical knots that it ties itself and
do it doesn't know how to get out of
without cheating
oh and seriously the the image of the
Statue of Liberty as a weeping angel is
stupid on its face like here's the thing
I would love to have seen that as like a
piece of concept or something they
didn't do or a piece of fan art that'd
be really neat but in a story it makes
zero freaking sense it freezes whenever
people look at it you're telling me that
in New York the city that never sleeps
this thing walks down the street you can
hear its steps kun kun kun nobody looks
out their window and goes oh my god is a
Statue of Liberty and then like a bunch
of people stick their heads out now the
things stuck there for friggin ever
because everyone's staring at it yeah
like I get why the idea of the visual of
the Statue of Liberty as an angel was
like cool but it's really dumb it's
really stupid if you stop to think about
it for any more than two seconds and
yeah that that is the biggest leap the
biggest what the heck and there are a
lot of other smaller ones there's a line
there
Rumour Has about they seem to have taken
over nearly every statue in New York
which is weird because we've never had
the idea that the Angels take over
existing statues only that they pass
themselves off as statues so that was a
little bit of a weird basically a fix-it
line you know toss that in to try and
explain some of this even though we
can't possibly explain the Statue of
Liberty thing but at the same time even
though I say that I do like that in many
ways this story is paying off the tease
at the end of Blink where it has all
these shots of all these statues that
are real statues in the world that makes
you under wait a minute and I kind of
like that they're now finally paying
that off by having not just the classic
we beams that we know but the little
cherubs which I thought that was a neat
idea I thought they were creepy I love
the image of the one frozen and blows
out the match that was great so it keeps
it keeps having these ideas with parts
that I'm like nice and then other parts
of that same idea where I'm like what
but that's the thing the logistics are a
mess but honestly emotionally I do think
this episode of works very very well it
does not lose sight of the lesson that
has been learned repeatedly and
repeatedly reinforced that Amy and Rory
are in this together and they will be
each of them will give up whatever they
have to to be with or save the other and
we see that reiterated again multiple
times in this episode so that was right
it felt very appropriate that Amy says
goodbye to the doctor so that she could
be with Rory because that is a choice
she has made repeatedly and so that is
the choice that she had to make again
now I really like in the graveyard how
the doctor the doctor at this point just
kind of can't cope she's going no don't
do this and River recognizing this is
what is right for her and unselfishly
encouraging Amy to go would be with Rory
because River understands that that's
the choice she has to make or as the
doctor selfishly just doesn't want that
to happen he doesn't like endings he
doesn't like goodbyes and I do also like
the idea that he tears the last page out
of a book but then has to run back and
get it again so that he can get
Amy's passing message to him I thought
that was really nice and really sweet
and like I said I'd forgotten how good
River was in this she is she has her
usual witty things she has good flirty
banter with the doctor but she's got
some good emotional beats when she's
talking to Amy me like don't let him
know how much this hurts and don't let
him see you age you know you get that
melancholy in her performance that I
love when that sneaks in under all the
fun with River and again what she did
the graveyard was great but also just
that emotional link between Amy and the
doctor and the pain of watching it get
severed is sold really really well Karen
Gillan knocks it out of the park and
Matt Smith does very good work as well
but I do think Karen Gillan is carrying
this scene pretty much on her shoulders
and it really really works so the Angels
Take Manhattan is an odd mix of
emotional awesomeness which is funny
because so I see so many people
criticize Moffat for not being able to
tell good emotional stories or good
character stories like this is a great
emotional story the logistics are nuts
and don't work at all which people also
say was off its strong suit so like this
is an episode of her like pin in my
brain to point out like okay you people
who say he only is interested in
seamless plot mechanics and doesn't do
emotions like Yuri watched ages in Manan
lately because that's a complete inverse
of what you say that having been said I
do actually agree with that
as a broad sentiment but never let it be
said that he is either incapable of
displaying good proper well-earned
emotions with characters nor is he
incapable of
screwing up the logistics he can swing
in either direction even though
generally that is a correct assessment
he favors the the logic puzzles over the
emotional resonance but here is flipped
on its head and I do enjoy it despite my
niggles it's one of those things where
you kind of have to set the logistics
aside and just let it wash over you
because otherwise you can nitpick this
thing to death angels in Manhattan or
take Manhattan I forget which one it is
now whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it bunch of stuff to do like
subscribe it helps me out and the
algorithm which seems to be iffy with me
lately although it is with a lot of
people so it's not like it's targeted or
anything but you know how it is so share
this around that's immensely appreciated
I have a patreon if you want to help me
out that way as well that's even more
appreciated but you don't have to do any
of that because end of the day you're
the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]